imaginen un mundo en el que ya no
necesitamos el petróleo en el que las
centrales nucleares han quedado
obsoletas e incluso la energía solar y
eólica son cosas del pasado
[Música]
esta visión va camino a convertirse en
realidad aquí en el instituto
tecnológico de massachusetts en eeuu
sí
es en este laboratorio de acceso
controlado donde se genera la fusión
la llamada energía del futuro que podría
sustituir a todas las demás formas de
energía
estamos ante un avance que lleva a la
fusión a ser una energía de fusión
práctica para el uso de la humanidad
mucho antes de lo esperado
[Música]
hace unos diez años llegue a un punto en
el que pensaba que la fusión no iba a
cambiar nada en mi vida
el
lugar fue uno de los estudiantes de
doctorado de wight y ahora forma parte
de un equipo que dirige la investigación
a través de una start-up de lehman que
intenta encontrar nuevas vías para poner
en práctica las ideas
nos gusta pensar que se trata de una
carrera contra el reloj o cambio
climático marca el reloj nosotros
corremos la carrera cocinar la energía
de fusión es fundamentalmente la fuente
de energía de las estrellas es lo que da
energía
el sol se lee sobre la energía de fusión
en los cómics pero hay que recordar que
estamos innovando constante y
entonces cómo funciona exactamente esta
energía de las estrellas
la energía nuclear tradicional se
produce al dividir un átomo de uranio
emitiendo así energía la energía de
fusión en cambio se genera por la unión
de dos átomos y puede lograrse con solo
dos átomos de hidrógeno el elemento más
común en el universo que no emite
radiación y no produce contaminación
los científicos de todo el mundo llevan
décadas trabajando para avanzar en esta
forma de energía el ejemplo más
destacado es el iter un mega proyecto
internacional de fusión en el sur de
francia en haití su mayor progreso en 30
años es gracias a este revolucionario
imán este tipo concreto de imán está
construido con un tipo de material
totalmente nuevo en un nuevo
superconductor que ganó el premio nobel
en realidad propio material es una
herramienta completamente nueva cuando
se aplica a la fusión significa máquinas
de fusión mucho más inteligentes para
que la fusión sea útil los científicos
tienen que desencadenar la de forma que
se obtenga mucho más energía de la que
se introduce una forma de conseguirlo es
utilizar imanes para contener el plasma
el cuarto estado de la materia después
del sólido el líquido y el gas se forma
a millones de grados y por lo tanto debe
controlarse cuidadosamente
ya que la temperatura extrema fundiría
instantáneamente las infraestructuras
circundantes al entrar en contacto aquí
es donde entran los imanes
ahora mismo estoy empujando el plasma
lejos de mí y hacia el tubo de vidrio
del otro lado
y si le doy la vuelta tirará del plasma
hacia mí así esta es la forma de
sostener algo sin sujetarlo físicamente
y ese es el principio que utilizamos
excepto si usamos los imanes los cuales
pueden hacer campos magnéticos mucho más
fuertes en la carrera contra el cambio
climático la energía de fusión podría
suponer un cambio decisivo para nuestro
futuro energético mundial
[Música]
los átomos de hidrógeno de varios litros
de agua podrían alimentar ciudades
enteras una energía limpia e inagotable
que es extremadamente rentable
y
podemos utilizarla para fabricar
electricidad pero también para muchas
otras cosas desalinización combustibles
ecológicos procesamiento químico
cualquier cosa que utiliza energía bien
y se espera que en los próximos años los
científicos e ingenieros desarrollen las
primeras centrales de fusión del tamaño
de una pista de tenis su despliegue en
el mundo podría comenzar ya en la
próxima década en la década de 2030
[Música]